what's up guys
we are pongfinity today we're playing a
tournament with the bottom
of the racket for five points yeah no
two point difference
[Music]
i know
[Music]
look how low he is he's really in the
position i've never seen that before
[Music]
no
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what he played it like off the side
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm sorry
what can he do he's just putting it on
come on all right
[Music]
yeah there we have the smash
i tried to distract you i don't know
what that was
[Music]
no wait
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Laughter]
how is that even possible that was the
short of the day
i never thought that playing with the
butt of the racket could be this intense
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
injury time out for air we need a medic
so we had our
medical team have a look at it i got
some like eight to ten stitches and
i'm ready
[Music]
is
[Applause]
it was a good match of a tight match and
you gave everything you got
even a piece of your skin and don't
forget to hit subscribe
and watch our previous episodes there
until next time